let's talk about the biggest opening of
tom cruise's career
let's talk about a movie that is
reminding the movie industry that a
summer blockbuster can happen how does
all this feel
i mean it's crazy uh you know this is
this is what we hope for you know when
we were filming this tom kept saying you
know we were trying to hit a bullet with
a bullet and uh
we hit a bullet with a big old bullet uh
apparently he bombed the bullet yeah we
bombed the bullet uh this is amazing you
know i think for for movie lovers all of
us who made this movie we grew we grew
up loving movies obviously we got into
it for that reason and to see this come
full circle and and people enjoy this
experience in theaters again
and have a summer blockbuster this is
wild
this is crazy
how are you all celebrating together as
a task
as a cast like glenn's here tonight have
you been group like are you texting with
tom cruise about the number we are we
are all uh yeah i text tom yesterday
about the numbers actually i know glenn
talked to him earlier this week uh danny
was staying at my house last night
tarzan's been over my house three times
this week i faced time with monica
friday uh this has been why and i faced
time with lewis yesterday danny and i
facetime facetimed louis yesterday we're
all talking nonstop it's crazy
it's been a year's long process i mean
is tom happy with the numbers tom is
happy tom's smiling tom is somewhere
smiling right now he's got a big old
big old smile smiling and running and
landing a plane and jumping off exactly
we gotta ask look people are now falling
in love with the new recruits could we
get a top gun three with this new new
class listen from your lips to god's
ears uh you know it took time a while to
make this movie for a couple different
reasons you know part of it was
technology and being able to push the
limits of film uh you know so i think if
we were to do a three like that would be
that would be up we'd have to push the
limit of what we just were able to
accomplish and then on top of that being
able to tell a story that is relevant
for the time that we're in
having blown away the box office truly
out from the movie industry i say thank
you for reminding us it can happen how
do you feel i know it's the best i mean
the fact that everybody we made this
movie we obviously put everything we had
in this movie but i don't think anybody
expected it to be what it is
you know he said tom was smiling did you
have you talked to tom how does he feel
about the numbers talked to tom a few
days ago he seems to be in a very good
mood
he's got a big old smile i'm telling you
yeah he's always got a big smile but
this one feels extra big extra big right
now and then i just asked him look we've
fallen in love with the new recruits we
love them we got hangman we got payback
we love them can we love and see them in
a top gun three
i've already answered now this is your
turn that's classified
off my test above my pay grade that's
for sure
since you guys have tom cruise on you
know your favorites and your in your
cell phone have you discussed this with
tom
the the top gun three i have not have
you
i wouldn't dare yeah i'm
just trying to get through this you know
what i don't know
yeah you know
that's the other thing is like i really
think just enjoying this moment has been
just absolutely special and just
um i mean it really has been the most
beautiful ride and like start to finish
just been incredible but
um if there is a top gun three we just
have to figure out new cool things to do
with f-18s yeah just flip a plane
horizontally
last question i got to ask you
tick tock is very in love with the
football scene um and miles and his
dancing and his mustache what is the
cast reaction to that
i i i told miles i was texting with
miles about five minutes before this and
i just said he kicked off pride month in
the best way anyone has ever kicked off
this is going to be a pride for
the century this is going to be one to
remember all thanks to miles teller uh
yeah he he's really started a revolution
i'm very proud of him yeah can you guys
do the move like is it it's a lean i
don't really belong to miles and what it
is and to be honest with you it's a
miles teller specialty
yeah he served it up right and really we
owe a lot to him